[Music]
so finally all the stores have made it
safely to Mono whoa but uh about time
everyone got reunited after all that's
happened whoa whoa whoa wait it just
feels really good to have the entire
crew back in one spot but brago what
about jimbe who the hell is Jim Bay I'm
glad you asked I think it goes without
saying that Oda is a great fan of themes
and patterns when it comes to writing
his story no matter if it's the distinct
way he builds every single arc or his
affinity for the number-3 Oda clearly
likes to bring some elements of
structure into his enormous world
building the example that you might be
most familiar with though is the
distinct pattern based on which he has
been building the straw hat crew every
straw hat has a tragic backstory that
has left them emotionally struggling
every straw hat has the dream that they
can pursue by joining Luffy but most
importantly every straw hat has stuck
with Luffy and dedicated his life to him
ever since meeting him and that is where
Jim Bay comes into play because not only
has he been the only new crew member to
join after the time-skip
but he also hasn't traveled with the
crew even a single time how is that wise
Jim bees are so very different from the
other straw hats even though he fulfills
pretty much all of the criteria that
constitute a true straw hat with the
introduction of his character Oda has
deliberately broken the pattern for how
a new straw hat is supposed to join the
crew as we will see there are three big
reasons for this the purpose of the time
skip the complex political structures of
the new world but most importantly Jim
Bay's selfless personality not only does
all of this make him a unique member of
the crew but also an incredibly
intricate character that keeps impacting
the story in quite significant ways and
if we just take a step back we will see
that Jim Bay's character actually
embodies a central moral message that
Oda tackles within the story so let's
take a closer look at the huntsmen of
the straw hats and what role he has to
play in the story of one piece
oh and before we get going as you know
Jim Bay is the last official member of
the straw hats so that would make this
video the very last in this series but
since it seems like you guys are really
enjoying watching these and I really
love making them I figured we might keep
this up a little longer so why not make
this a bit of a challenge for all of us
if this video gets two thousand likes
within the first 24 hours the next
character analysis will be out within a
week a true challenge for you guys I
think but especially one for me since I
usually take at least twice that time to
make a video like this also pause this
video for a second head down to the
comment section and type in the
character or group that you think I
should be doing next the comment with
the most likes gets himself a video
maybe already next week so smash that
like button
but now let's dive right into the world
of our karate loving fishman when we
look at his backstory we will not only
see that it fulfills the requirements
for being a straw hat but also gives us
the first clue to why Jim Bay can
sometimes feel a bit out of focus and
hard to grasp in the story being the
only non-human in the crew next to
chopper who at least ate the human human
fruit Jim Bay is the first straw hat
that brings the issue of racial
inequality into the crew as a result his
past as a fisherman is very different
from any of the other straw hats
Jim Bay grew up as an orphan on Fishman
Island together with our long and fish'
taiga from an early age on he practiced
fishman karate a powerful martial art
that he managed to master like no other
when he grew older he joined the Royal
military but left after a few years
after his friend Fisher Tyga invaded
Meru jock and he decided to join the son
pirates instead having witnessed all the
injustice that the fisherman had to
suffer by the hand of the human
young djembe is rather violent and
hateful we can see him brutally beating
unconscious Marines accusing them of
tolerating slavery and the
discrimination on his people slowly
however that sentiment begins to change
as fish' Tyga passes his vision for
peace between the races down to djembe
he manages to make him more aware of the
endless cycle of hate and revenge
between fishermen and humans that has to
be broken a few years later the son
pirates meet the former human slave girl
koala after taking her in Jim Bay
realized how traumatized she was and
starts to build a relationship with her
he starts to understand that not all
humans are evil and that fishermen
aren't the only ones to suffer under the
reign of the world governments when they
finally reach koalas village however
they are ambushed by the Marines and
fish a tiger is fatally wounded in the
process after this heavy blow
Jim Bay becomes the new captain of the
Sun pirates despite also having to
witness ultra hemas death by the end of
the temmie Obito later Jim Bay decides
to take on his former captain's dream
and try to break the wheel of hate he
becomes one of the achiever Kai joining
forces with the world government that he
despises so much in order to protect his
people however when white bear declares
war over aces execution Jim Bay refuses
to answer the government's call after
all white beard had been protecting
Fishman Island under his flag as a
result Jim Bay is stripped of his rank
and thrown into level six of him bow
down he ends up in the same cell as ace
this is where we first get to meet him
in the story so as you can see Jim Bay
clearly fulfills the criteria of having
a tragic backstory not only have the
Fishman been suffering as a race
collectively for many centuries but Jim
Bay also had to witness the consequences
of racial inequality through the deaths
of many people close to him as we will
see racism is the great theme of Jim
Bay's character arc however before we
can look at how Jim Bay carries that
theme throughout the plot we first have
to understand the kind of person he is
in general now guys pay attention
in a way you could argue that jimbe is
what Brooke might have been to the crew
hadn't even stranded in the Florian
trying over fifty years of his life the
Fishman is a veteran pirate that has a
very holistic understanding of the
political and social workings of the
Wampus world since his tragic past as
well as the responsibility for his
people weigh heavily on his shoulders
Jim Bay usually presents himself as a
very serious and proud warrior however
if the circumstances allow for it he
shows us his light-hearted and gentle
side at times I would argue that this
side comes a lot closer to what Jim
based true-self would really be if you
took away all the hardship in his life
so if you ever wondered why Jim Bay
needs the straw hats in the first place
this is why Jim Bay can learn to enjoy
life again and can allow himself to drop
his shell when being with the crew
however he also brings a lot to luffy
and the others in return
first and foremost having been part of
the Chichibu kai for 11 years
Jim Bay is not only a valuable source of
knowledge and experience but also brings
significant fighting power to the crew
this is complemented by the fact that he
has mastered Fishman karate possibly
making him one of the strongest fighters
on the water
apart from battle though Jim Bay also
takes the role of the helmsman while the
crew somehow managed so far without one
whole cake island really showed us how
valuable it can be to have this position
filled with someone who knows what
they're doing
beside that though being a Fishman Jim
Bay is also able to control the sea
currents and even talk to the creatures
of the ocean all of these skills make
him
upgrade to the Sun that will surely have
to face more and more dangerous
situations like these in the future from
an internal perspective jimbe
psychological need has been constantly
shifting over the course of the story
which speaks for really well writing
from odesite it keeps the story vivid
and gives us continuous character
development in general Jim bass need is
always focused around his initial hatred
towards the humans for what they did to
his people he needs to find a way to
break the wheel of hatred inside himself
before he can start breaking the wheel
in general especially in his younger
years this moral need also affects those
around him we can see this in his
violence against humans but also in the
indifference he shows for auto he missed
ream to facilitate peace however as we
all know Jim Bay gets a significant
amount of character development over the
course of time as a result his initial
hate towards the humans slowly but
steadily shifts and finally Jim Bay
acquires his dream that is a crucial
element of becoming a straw hats his
dream is to make coexistence equality
and friendship between humans and
fishermen possible and put his people
out of the misery and that they have
been suffering for centuries as a result
Jim Bay has built a distinct set of
values over the course of his life that
fully reflect this change in character
being a proud warrior of the sea Jim Bay
has a strong sense of loyalty and duty
no matter the circumstances
Jim Bay always tries to act honorable
and true to his word while he
prioritizes the loyalty towards his
people and towards luffy over all else
he still tries to avoid going back on
his word as hard as possible we can see
this in the relationship with the world
governments to which he stayed faithful
until they threatened to take down the
man who was protecting his people or in
his relationship with big mom who he
tries to compensate fairly by bringing
her pony glyph before asking to leave
her crew in order to join Luffy this
also reflects in Jim Bay strong belief
in taking responsibility for your
actions he expects this from others but
mostly from himself for example he backs
Nami for forgiveness for our Long's
treatment often
feeling responsible for letting Arlen go
and do as he pleased
due to his life experience Jim Bay also
sees the importance of thoughtfulness in
your actions he always seems to think
things through and then reach a
conclusion to win and how something
should be done did he join Luffy right
on Fishman Island which he clearly
wanted to do No
he waits for the right moment in order
to not cause any trouble for Luffy or
his people and that already brings us to
Jim Bay's most defining trait his sense
of selflessness like no other character
in the story does he Center his life
around that of others
Jim Bay would die for his people or
falou fee their fate is what keeps him
going whether it's protecting Luffy from
a canoe by taking the hit himself or
protecting his people from exploitation
by becoming a pirate and a lying himself
with forces like the world government or
big mom Jim Bay truly takes altruism to
the next level all this makes Jim Bay a
central driver of the plot in the story
he saves loopy multiple times during the
war at marine fort insuring his survival
and on hoecake island is he not only the
one to free Luffy and Nami from big mobs
capture but later also lets the crew
safely escape the grasp of Leon go by
steering the sunny and later staying
behind to hold off the enemies so now
that we know what defines Jim Bay as a
character in the story
let's now finally look at his character
arc now listen closely
based on his background and especially
the intention behind the Fishman Island
arc the big theme of Jim Bay's character
is racial inequality discrimination and
racism as a whole every aspect of his
development arc revolves around events
that highlight the different sides of
the conflict between humans and fishman
I don't want to get too deep into why
the theme of Fishman Island was racism
and how older draws parallels to our
society I think that would need an
entire video on its own but I think we
can all agree that with Jim Bay oda
tries to introduce a character that
struggles with the way his people are
treated by the rest of the world and at
the same time tries to work for a better
future obviously his backstory sets the
premise for this development being
exposed to the cruelty towards his
people young Jim Bay develops a deep
hatefulness towards the humans after
inheriting Fisher Tigers will and
meeting the former slave girl koala
however Jim Bay develops a more refined
view of the humans and while he still
resents the way that humans ruled the
world and suppress other races he also
understands that this is not true for
all of them and learns that other humans
also have to suffer from their system as
well as a result he overcomes his first
moral need and starts dedicating his
life to creating a more positive world
for the Fishman now however we see Jim
Bay being caught in between his
resentment and his wish to make peace
with the humans working for the world
government violates his ideals and he
emotionally suffers from supporting the
cause in exchange for his people's
safety this is where marine 4 comes into
play he decides to trust and support
whitebeard's who has decided to put
Fishman Island under his protection now
he has actually formed a connection with
humans that value him and his people
solely for who they are as a person and
again he has to see them being crushed
by the
so now having lost his strongest lead to
a peaceful and friendly future through
whitebeard's death
Jim Bain now needs to find new hope for
his dream and that brings us to Fishman
Island where Jim Bay truly befriends
Luffy whom he had learned to respect you
the war here he sees someone who truly
doesn't know understand the concept of
racism but only wants to help people and
sail to sea together with his crew that
this crew involves a talking reindeer a
skeleton and a cyborg as well as people
like Nico Robin that have also suffered
heavily from the cruelty of the world
governments are all factors that have a
big impact on djembe but probably none
as big as meeting Nami a human who now
in return has suffered heavily under the
retaliating hate that are long has
brought with him towards the u-men's
seeing that Nami bears no ill feelings
towards his people anymore despite what
happened to her surely makes Luffy and
the straw hats the new sources for his
hope all that is left for him now to do
is fulfilling his dream and also find
joy for himself once again in his life
that he has solely dedicated to others
seeing on whole cake Island how big
mom's forced idea of a coexistence of
the racist doesn't work finally being
able to officially join the straw hats
was a big step in that direction for him
and the great thing with Jim Bay is that
with this final need for happiness still
not fulfilled he actually has some real
character development left in the story
for him to happen making him a very
fascinating character so who the hell is
Jim Bay Jim Bay is one of the most
symbolic and moral heavy characters in
entire series not only has he shaped
some of the most significant events in
the current storyline but he also has
been going through one of the most
complex and long-lasting character arcs
in the story by far he has managed to
break the wheel of hate between Fishman
and humans and is now striving for a
better and safer future for his people
were equal and peaceful coexistence
between the races is possible so why did
ona make an exception with Jim Bay and
didn't let him join the crew right away
reason one was the purpose of the
after the time-skip it was ODIs task to
show us how each of the straw hats had
grown and how the crew of rookies has
now become a real pirate crew that can
play with the pros secondly the complex
political structures of the new world
with all the players in lofty would have
been far less interesting to explore
with someone in the crew who knew about
all of this but most importantly it was
Jim BAE's selfless personality that led
him to prioritize the well-being of his
people over joining in on the adventure
right away keeping his relationship with
big mom was crucial to not spark
conflict for his country as a result he
hasn't joined up with the crew yet he
doesn't feel like a real straw head yet
and still has gotten way more character
development and action and some other
crew members I feel like that is the
main reason many people have
difficulties accepting Jim Bay as part
of the crew however I will promise you
that once he joins up with the crew that
will change because not only does our
whaleshark fulfill all requirements to
be part of the crew he also brings a lot
more to the story in terms of symbolism
and personality he's someone living for
his captain and his people a truly
selfless man hey everybody thank you so
much for watching I know that this video
was a little different than usual
nonetheless I think it shows us how much
thought Oda puts into many of the
concepts introduces what are your
thoughts on Jim Bay let me know in the
comments below
a big shoutout goes to my friend Bravo
who was kind enough to help me with this
project in the unlikely case you don't
know who he is make sure to check out
his amazing work on his two channels the
link is right at the beginning of the
description also if you enjoyed this
content and want to see more of its
please don't forget to smash that like
button share the video and subscribe to
be notified for any future content of
mine or dislike don't share and
unsubscribe it's a free world people I
hope to see around next time and until
then have a great week
oh yeah and don't forget to turn your
notifications on because YouTube can
sometimes be forgetful I
[Music]